One common method of authenticating with
applications is SAML. This stands for
the security assertion markup language.
This is an open standard for
authentication and it allows an
application to use a different
authentication source to provide access
to the app. Although SAML works well for
using web- based applications, it was
not designed for mobile apps. So you may
find that mobile apps are using a
different process of authentication than
using
SAML. The authentication flow with SAML
is relatively straightforward. There are
three devices involved in this SAML
workflow. We'll start with the one that
you're using. It's your laptop. You're
probably in a browser. We refer to this
as the client machine. We also have a
device that we'd like to access. So
we'll need some type of authentication
to access our resource server. And
lastly, there is an authorization server
that's going to check our credentials
and give us access to the resource
server. We start with our browser
accessing a URL that's located on this
resource server. And that server is
going to respond back with a signed and
encrypted SAML request. This is sent
directly back to you on the client.
Inside of that request is a redirection
to an authorization server. The user is
then presented with a login page and
provides the authentication credentials.
If everything matches, the authorization
server will confirm the authentication
and it will create a sample token and
provide that token to the client. The
client then presents that sample token
to the resource server and the resource
server now knows that the client must
have authenticated properly and provides
them with access to the
app. This is often integrated with a
single sign on process or SSO. This
prevents the process of providing a
username and password every time you
need to access a different resource on
that network. We obviously don't want
this single sign on to be something that
is perpetual. So, normally it will time
out usually in about 24 hours and after
that timer expires, we simply provide
our username and password and we get
another 24 hours of access. The
authentication process that's being used
in your environment must support SSO for
this to operate and not all
authentication protocols provide support
for single signon. But if you are using
single sign on, it makes the process of
using multiple resources much
easier. We often mention that a good
security best practice is to prevent the
use of an administrator account on all
of your systems, but somebody on the
network needs to be the administrator.
In many organizations, there's one or
more people in the IT department that
have administrator access. And in the
past, it was very common to have that
person have administrative access
associated with their standard account.
This means they were able to perform any
type of function required by simply
logging in with their normal user
account. This also means, of course,
that the administrator's account becomes
a very valuable account to an attacker.
If a third party somehow gains access to
that user's login, they would
effectively have administrator access to
the entire network. To prevent this from
occurring, we can implement a just in
time access. This means that the user
getting administrative access would only
have that access for a limited amount of
time. This means that they can perform
whatever task is required that needs
elevated access and then that access is
revoked after a certain amount of time.
So in an environment where you're using
just in time access, even if the
attacker gains access to the IT user's
account, they still would not have
administrator rights. The way this
usually works is the person needing the
administrator access would request that
level of access from a central clearing
house and there's usually additional
authentication associated with that. The
actual administrator's account is stored
in a password vault and the vault is
controlling who gets access to these
particular credentials. Instead of
gaining access to the actual
administrator account, this just in time
access will create a new account with
administrator access. But that account
will be timelimited. The IT personnel
will receive these ephemeral credentials
and eventually those credentials will
time out and no longer be available.
This means that the original
administrator credentials are still in
the password vault and no one ever
received those original credentials. All
they received was a separate
time-sensitive set of credentials and
once those credentials time out, they
are deleted and cannot be used again. If
you need to provide access for your
administration team to be able to
perform their job but still protect your
administrator accounts, you may want to
look into just in time access.
We refer to the process of managing
these super user accounts as privileged
access management or PAM. This is one
that is associated with a Windows
administrator account, a Linux root
account or any account that has
additional rights and permissions. The
process we described of just in time
access is part of this privileged access
management. Not only does this
centralize all of these privilege
accounts and provide access to that in a
secure way, we also have automation that
can be associated with this. So now, not
only do we have administrative accounts
that are in a protected secure vault,
but we're able to automate access to
those and have extensive tracking and
auditing. This is an important
consideration, especially in
environments where you want to be sure
that those administrative accounts are
tightly controlled. Everyone in your
organization has a mobile phone, a
tablet, or perhaps even both. These are
obviously powerful tools for the
organization, but they can be a
challenge to manage. In order to provide
administration of all of these systems
that are constantly in motion, you need
to have mobile device management or MDM.
Mobile device managers allow the IT
department to manage all of these mobile
devices from one central console. This
may be devices that are owned by the
company or it may be devices that users
have brought into the organization as
their personal phone. We often refer to
this as BYOD or bring your own device.
Mobile device management allows you to
centralize the management so that all of
these devices can be managed from one
central console. This certainly saves
time for the administrator and they're
able to see where all of these devices
might be anywhere in the world. The
management part of the mobile device
manager allows the administrator to
define what each device is able to do.
They can set parameters for security.
They can define what applications can
run on this device and they can set up a
separate partition for the company's
data. This is especially important if
you're using BYOD where some of the data
on the device is personal data for that
user and other data on the device is
owned by the company. If the user was to
leave the organization, the MDM can
delete the company's data while leaving
the user's information in place. And of
course, security is an important
consideration. And from the central
console, you can have policies that
require that everyone have a lock
screen. They use a personal
identification number on the lock
screen. And you can set all of the
detailed parameters for all of these
security features.
We transfer sensitive information across
our networks all the time, but it may be
important to know where that sensitive
information is going. And you may want
to set policies that prevents that
sensitive info from getting outside of
your organization. One way that you can
do that is through the use of data loss
prevention or DLP. This allows an
administrator to manage sensitive
information such as social security
numbers, credit card numbers, medical
records, and any other type of personal
data. With DLP, we can identify the
sensitive information and set policies
on how this information should be
transferred from one place to another.
Most organizations will use multiple
types of data loss prevention. There
might be clients on the endpoints. There
might also be DLP installed on the
cloud-based systems and you might have
DLP functionality built into your email
server or even your firewall. This means
that information that is properly
secured can be transferred or sent to
the appropriate resource and information
that might be sent in the clear across
the network is stopped before it gets
into the hands of someone who should not
be viewing
it. Our organizations used to have all
of our applications located in our data
center and you would access them through
an executable on your desktop. But these
days, we have applications that are on
our desktop, on our mobile devices, and
they may be located anywhere in the
world. Not just in our private data
center, but in cloud-based data centers
that may be located in multiple cloud
providers. We also have more than just
employees that are using these apps. We
might have employees, customers,
contractors, and other people accessing
these applications at any particular
time. The challenge is making sure that
the person who needs access to the data
gets exactly the type of data that's
required for their particular job
function. We might have employees that
need additional access to data and there
might be customers that should only be
seeing the data associated with
themselves. To be able to manage all of
this, we need identity and access
management or AM. This provides a set of
life cycle management for the identity
of people. Every person and every device
is granted a digital identity which now
allows us to manage that device or that
individual. Every individual and every
device gets a digital identity and we
can provide access control to all of
that so that each entity only gets
access to the data that's required. We
can provide authentication and
authorization. So we can set up strong
login processes with multiple factors
and we can prove that the person logging
in is really the person they say they
are. And in many organizations we need
to be able to track this entire process.
It may be important to know when a
particular customer accesses a
particular resource and we might want to
perform standard auditing for our
employees to make sure that they are
only accessing the information necessary
to perform their job. And in some
organizations there is a regulatory
requirement to keep track of where all
this data exists and how people are
accessing that data using identity and
access management. Our IT administrators
need to manage many different resources
on the network. There are many different
types of computing systems. We have
servers, user accounts, fileshares,
printers, and many, many other
resources. To be able to manage all of
these very different systems, we need
one single repository of information, a
single database that contains all of
these details. We often refer to this as
directory services. For example, if your
organization is using Microsoft Windows,
they're probably also using Active
Directory, which has the standard set of
directory services. Since all of these
resources are in one single place, we
can manage everything from one central
console. For example, your IT team can
manage the authentication that people
use to gain access to these resources
because all of the usernames and all of
the passwords are stored securely in
these directory services. We can also
centralize what type of access people
have once they provide their login. So
we can set up rights and permissions for
certain folders, certain printers, and
any other resource on the network. And
if you're part of a help desk, then
you're probably very familiar with
directory services because when somebody
calls in and needs to reset their
password, then we'll need to access
these directory services to make those
modifications.